that's why you wake up on Monday shitty
you're literally the hypothesis I have
of why people are unhappy
[Music]
get their attention
scary it's about to be legendary
[Music]
back in the straddle
um oh you did get a couple of uh Clips
before you got kicked out of the gym so
we started very early today 6 a.m
basketball
[Music]
QB for the many times
I don't try to put my game on get you
supposed to show because my wife should
put my chain on no my killing women ring
your Bells
Iraq I'm the mic well I'm on the mic
drock on the camera I know that's got
all the fans going crazy I'm excited to
jam with you it definitely levels up my
energy though Dustin's been crushing
million Julian's in the mix literally I
had to take a breath because I'm out of
breath from baldness basketball but I
was about to give Julian some
um some love as well big batch of
speakers for vcon all of you are
watching right now vcon May 18th to the
20th Indianapolis Indiana business
technology marketing pop culture super
conference uh By the time this airs some
of the new names are gonna be out there
so Neil Patrick Harris Andrew Schultz
doing the comedy set
um Busta Rhymes opening night tons of
CMOS and CEOs uh Damon Johns just like
loaded loaded loaded grupman the Miami
nightlife icon just like I mean there's
tons as a matter of fact drock or or uh
who's gonna who's gonna edit this one
you're gonna give me some give me some
direct right here I just bang out a
bunch of the names
our nft
tickets so uh in the copy of this post
send the email there we'll get you uh
hooked up hand to hand combat and get
you all situated you need to get to Indy
um go and get a haircut got a new Vader
sports hat that's pretty rad a lot going
on with Vayner Sports UFC exploding
baseball exploding football exploding
got the NFL draft coming up
um
make sure you look for our guys to
submitted work hit up Matt DeMayo he'll
get you the names root for those guys in
the draft ah lots of jets chatter with
number 12 Aaron Rodgers we'll see if
that news breaks today that'd be some
[__]
just working you know grinding I mean
Rex is busy be friends busy burn Island
great stuff link it up drock there's a
lot going on here in the opening it's on
here in the first two three minutes of
the show
but I'm excited so
walking into the building
that's all I got
uh morning talk what am I thinking about
these days thinking a lot about
forgiveness
um humongous Mistake by so many of you
holding grudges
not realizing that the anger and
jealousy and envy and pain and
disappointment you have inside is
actually eating you up
be the bigger person and approach the
person that you're upset with and
forgive them for their mistake forgive
them because you're actually forgiving
them for you it helps you move on and
build every human makes mistakes
sometimes big ones but the capacity to
forgive will always keep you in a really
nice place
get the poison out have the conversation
share your feelings you might not even
get a good response from the person that
made the mistake because they're still
in a hurt Zone
but when you don't do things expecting a
reaction from others
you don't do nice things with
expectation you do nice things to do
nice things
it can help you so much and so that's on
my mind a lot drock I think a lot of
people don't understand that
um that they need to learn how to
forgive it's holding back so many people
and just hurting you
and really it's a it's a tell of what's
going on in you it's a weakness within
you if you're unable to forgive
people take oh I'm so
um
a lot of that shit's on you
you know what I mean
right
it sure does Andy did not play
basketball this morning which was
devastating
he's did you say happy birthday to drock
Andy
all right all right
James good job
okay
what are we doing here
merch is Marcus okay what would you need
for me I want to take you to Paris to
spoil you I want to go to my saying
enjoy you I want those guys in your DM
to talk to themselves and then tell are
they friends that they know you I want
to make you forget about your ex I want
you overthinking on your ex I want the
neighbors to hear you again told me
she's a CEO I can tell so you do you and
I'll do me but when we come together we
come together
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
look first and foremost I you know and
please feel free to use the chat as I'm
talking to all of you like what really
hopeful and and kind of I'm sensing that
this has been a fruitful program so far
um that The Residency is going quite
well I'm hearing I'm just gonna be very
transparent I'm hearing
really strong feedback as a collective
class I think that has to do with all of
you but I also think it has to do with
us I think we've gotten stronger at it
this is truly one of my favorite parts
of our business
um you know watching even already in a
short time that we've done it watching
residents go from Residency program to
like Rising Stars amongst the rap ranks
here at Vayner has been very fruitful is
one of the most exciting things for me
and
um would love to uh get into the Q a I
think that's the punch line
um let's just get right into it so I'm
on the team here in LA and uh my
question for you is uh going back to
Taylor is that how do you wake up early
in the morning on a Monday and to stay
hungry you know
um I'm 27 and I'm trying to keep myself
going every day and I kind of struggle
sometimes so what is your take on that
what do you struggle with brother
I think just being motivated to get to
my angle you know what's your end goal
honestly six figures have a big house
I'm being a little materialistic but
well that's what that's why you're
struggling
yeah I mean I would have bet the I mean
you couldn't have walked into that more
that if I paid you to say what you just
said
you're literally the hypothesis I have
of why people are unhappy
you just made up an arbitrary goal for
yourself based on material things
without realizing the second you walk
into that home and you make six figures
nothing's changed
[Music]
thank you
damn that was
I would rather be you know have someone
be honest with me you know so I'm I'm
even better brother I'm telling you from
the deepest levels of love that you can
even imagine
I know you I've met a thousand of you
all of them have lost the second they
got there
you're you've got you've been able to
turn your perspective to something
that's very easy to turn your
perspective to the world is very good at
selling this
it's just super not true bro
I appreciate it thank you and kind of
going adding to that like what keeps
what like what should we do you know or
like yeah I mean I think I I the
alternative to that is
focusing on doing things you like
[Music]
what do you like Joe
uh Sports and videography actually right
so you should and what are you doing
[Music]
um I do the media action the media
analyst you can't do that
yeah like I'm gonna look very carefully
to see if they're going to give you a
full-time media job and I'm gonna say no
I'm gonna say this dude needs to make he
needs to be a Creator he needs to make
videos
Joe you just got fired and hired
[Laughter]
[Music]
I appreciate it thank you brother if
you're naturally good at math and you
think that's your quickest path to
making a hundred thousand dollars but
you don't love it that's why you wake up
on Monday shitty
yeah yeah
yep so team let's make sure let's get
him switched off and get him into
Creator land and let's see what happens
thank you I appreciate it you're welcome
[Music]
dailyvee what's good working on vcon
make sure you get there the lineup is
absurd Andrew Schultz Ariana Huffington
Timberland we just announced a bunch of
names Bobby hundreds like and next
week's gonna be even crazier Link in the
Bios
drock so fun to be with you again today
great I can't wait to see you edit this
um I'm hyped is it gonna take you like a
month out of this yeah we got a Mandy we
got him
[Music]
I'm focused I have very few friends
I wanna take you to Paris and spoil you
I want to go to my saying enjoy you I
want those guys in your DMs to talk to
themselves and then tell all their
friends that they know you I want to
make you forget about your ex I want you
overthinking on you